This is 99% invisible. I'm Delaney Hall, filling in for Roman Mars. Maybe you've heard a story like this, how once upon a time on the outskirts of the town where someone grew up or where they went to school, on the edge of the woods there was a scary old asylum. Over the last few years so many people have told me versions of this story. Over the last few years, so many people have told me versions of this story. That's writer Sandy Allen. They wrote a book called A Kind of Miraculous Paradise about mental health care in America. And often when somebody learns that I write about mental health, they will launch into their old asylum story, how they used to break into one with their friends or how someone they knew saw ghost there, the details
这里是《99%隐形》。我是德莱尼·霍尔，代班罗曼·马尔斯。也许你听过这样的故事：在某人成长或上学的小镇郊外，树林边缘有一座阴森恐怖的老精神病院。过去几年里，很多人都向我讲述过这个故事的各种版本。过去几年里，很多人都向我讲述过这个故事的各种版本。那是作家桑迪·艾伦。他们写了一本名为《一种奇迹般的乐园》的书，讲述美国的心理健康护理。通常当人们得知我撰写关于心理健康的文章时，他们就会开始讲述他们的老精神病院故事，比如他们如何和朋友闯入其中，或者他们认识的人在那里见过鬼，细节各不相同。
vary. But the one detail that almost never varies, the thing that seems to make an asylum story and asylum story, is that the asylum is nearly always abandoned. The former Buffalo State Asylum for the Insane is an imposing stone structure on the north side of Buffalo, New York. It's nearly 150 years old, and its resident historian Corey Fabian Barrett recently took me inside.
但有一个细节几乎从未改变，即让精神病院故事成为精神病院故事的那个要素，就是精神病院几乎总是废弃的。前布法罗州立精神病院是位于纽约州布法罗市北侧的一座宏伟石质建筑。它已有近150年的历史，其常驻历史学家科里·法比安·巴雷特最近带我走进了内部。
This is pretty much what happens in the early of a building so by itself, 40 years. The interior was everything you would expect from an old abandoned asylum with boarded up windows and long derelict corridors. You've got all the paint crumbling off the walls. You've got the paint crumbling off of the tin ceiling. Graffiti that says get out now.
这基本上就是一座建筑在被遗弃40年后会发生的情况。内部正如你对一座废弃老精神病院的预期，窗户被木板封死，走廊荒废已久。墙上的油漆剥落，铁皮天花板上的油漆也在剥落。涂鸦写着“现在就离开”。
Yeah. That's some of the Buffalo State College students from Nanyans. All of the doors had been taken off their hinges, parts of the building were charred black by fire. Yeah, there have been many fires here. So this fire actually took place in 1975, right after the patients moved out, but it didn't take the whole building.
是的。那是布法罗州立学院的学生留下的。所有的门都从铰链上拆了下来，建筑的部分区域被火烧得焦黑。是的，这里发生过很多次火灾。这场火灾实际上发生在1975年，就在病人们搬走之后，但它并没有烧毁整座建筑。
Nope, nope, fire department responded in the nick of time. Also, these buildings are built like medieval castles. And that's not an exaggeration. Even though the building was falling apart, it was clear that back in the day, it hadn't just been imposing but fancy. The floors had been laid with designer tile imported from England. The exterior was made with Medina sandstone. Buckingham Palace is faced in Medina sandstone. The Brooklyn bridge, Medina sandstone, like they did not skimp at all. But more than anything else, the main thing that stood out about the asylum at Buffalo State was its size. The building was huge over a third of a mile long. It boasted its own subway passage, so carriages could take people from one side of the building to the other.
不，不，消防部门及时赶到了。此外，这些建筑建造得像中世纪城堡一样。这并不夸张。尽管建筑正在倒塌，但很明显，在过去，它不仅宏伟，而且奢华。地板铺设了从英国进口的设计师瓷砖。外观由麦地那砂岩制成。白金汉宫的外墙就是麦地那砂岩。布鲁克林大桥也是麦地那砂岩，他们一点也没吝啬。但最重要的是，布法罗州立精神病院最突出的特点是它的规模。这座建筑非常巨大，全长超过三分之一英里。它拥有自己的地下通道，这样马车就可以把人从建筑的一侧运送到另一侧。
Today, there are more than a hundred abandoned asylum in the United States. Many of them not all that different from Buffalo State. It's one of the reasons we're also familiar with the idea of the big empty asylum in the woods. Few, however, stopped to wonder where all these structures came from. But in fact, the massive building, the impressive grounds, the fine materials, all of this was part of a treatment regimen developed by a singular Philadelphia doctor, a physician who was obsessed with architecture, and how it could be harnessed therapeutically to cure those who'd gone insane. Dr. Thomas Story Kirkbride.
今天，美国有超过一百座废弃的精神病院。其中许多与布法罗州立精神病院相差无几。这也是我们对树林中那座巨大空旷的精神病院的概念如此熟悉的原因之一。然而，很少有人停下来思考这些建筑从何而来。事实上，这些宏伟的建筑、令人印象深刻的场地、精美的材料，所有这些都是由一位独特的费城医生制定的治疗方案的一部分，这位医生痴迷于建筑，以及如何利用建筑进行治疗，以治愈那些精神失常的人。他就是托马斯·斯托里·柯克布赖德医生。
Dr. Kirkbride was an amazing man. When Cory Fabian Barrett speaks about Kirkbride, you cannot help but notice she is a fan. He was one of the first people in America to say there's something better we could be doing for people with mental illness, that it was something that could potentially be treated and cured, that it wasn't just a condition where you would lock somebody up in the basement and throw away the key.
柯克布赖德医生是一位了不起的人。当科里·法比安·巴雷特谈到柯克布赖德时，你不得不注意到她是他的粉丝。他是美国最早提出“我们可以为精神病患者做得更好”的人之一，他认为这是一种可以治疗和治愈的疾病，而不仅仅是一种把人锁在地下室并扔掉钥匙的状况。
Thomas Kirkbride was a quaker, born in the Pennsylvania countryside in 1809. His father was a farmer, but young Kirkbride discovered early on that he wasn't suited to farming, and he decided to become a doctor. At first he wanted to be a surgeon. Then he got kind of randomly talked into working instead at a Quaker run in St. Asylum outside of Philadelphia. A quick note about language. Historically, words that may sound offensive now, like insane or lunatic, would have been commonplace in the late 18th and early 19th century, even used by medical professionals. So for clarity's sake, we'll be using the terminology that Kirkbride would have used.
托马斯·柯克布赖德是一位贵格会教徒，1809年出生于宾夕法尼亚州的乡村。他的父亲是一名农民，但年轻的柯克布赖德很早就发现自己不适合务农，于是决定成为一名医生。起初他想成为一名外科医生。后来，他被随机说服去费城郊外的一家贵格会经营的精神病院工作。关于语言的一个简短说明：从历史上看，像“疯狂的”或“精神错乱的”这样现在听起来可能带有冒犯性的词汇，在18世纪末和19世纪初是司空见惯的，甚至被医学专业人士使用。因此，为了清晰起见，我们将使用柯克布赖德当时会使用的术语。
And back then, when someone was deemed insane, it was often thought to be the person's own fault. The assumption was they were, you know, forsaken by God, or they were possessed by demons, or they had done something to deserve to be in such a desperate condition. Carly Yani is an architectural historian at Rutgers, who wrote a book called The Architecture of Madness, and she says that what happened to someone who was labeled insane in the early 19th century would have depended mostly on their class.
在当时，当一个人被认为精神失常时，通常被认为是这个人自己的错。人们假设他们是被上帝遗弃了，或者被恶魔附身了，或者他们做了什么事才落得如此绝望的境地。卡莉·亚尼是罗格斯大学的建筑历史学家，她写了一本名为《疯狂的建筑》的书，她说，在19世纪初，被贴上精神失常标签的人的遭遇主要取决于他们的阶级。
Wealthy families often kept in stain relatives at home or paid for them to live in private mad houses. Poor people fared worse. Some of them were kind of cast out to walk along roads. A lot of them ended up in county jails. A lot of them ended up in some kind of, you know, small, privately run alms house. What mad houses did exist were more like prisons, largely focused on confining and often torturing people. In some, such as England's infamous Bedlam, the public could even pay to come
富裕家庭通常把精神失常的亲属留在家里，或者花钱让他们住在私人的疯人院里。穷人的境遇则更糟。有些人被赶出去在路上流浪。许多人最终进了县监狱。许多人最终进了某种小型、私人经营的济贫院。当时存在的疯人院更像是监狱，主要集中在监禁和经常折磨人。在一些地方，比如英国臭名昭著的贝特莱姆皇家医院，公众甚至可以付费进去嘲笑里面的人。
goch and laugh at those kept inside. People would go and look at the patients as if they were animals in a zoo. But at the Quakeres Island outside Philadelphia, called the Friends' Asylum, Thomas Kirkbride was exposed to something very different, a newer gentler philosophy of how to manage the people in their care. It was called moral treatment. And the starting idea was that the mentally ill person was not responsible for his or her illness. Pioneered by a small handful of the silums in Europe, moral treatment was part of a growing trend among professional physicians who believed that patients didn't have to be confined indefinitely.
人们会去观看病人，就像看动物园里的动物一样。但在费城郊外那家名为“朋友精神病院”的贵格会机构，托马斯·柯克布赖德接触到了非常不同的东西，一种更新、更温和的管理护理对象的方法。这被称为“道德治疗”。其基本理念是，精神病患者不对他或她的疾病负责。道德治疗由欧洲少数几家精神病院首创，是专业医生中日益增长的趋势的一部分，他们认为病人不必被无限期监禁。
Instead, they could be treated, even cured. That meant the person should get enough rest, should sleep on a regular schedule, should eat healthy food, should go for walks and get exercise, should go out and experience nature. All of those things were built into treatment. Kirkbride worked a few years at the Friends of Sylam, learning and practicing moral treatment. Then in 1840, he became super-intended of his own asylum, the Pennsylvania hospital for the insane. And it was here that he began thinking about
相反，他们可以得到治疗，甚至治愈。这意味着病人应该得到充足的休息，按规律作息，吃健康的食物，去散步和锻炼，去户外体验大自然。所有这些都被纳入了治疗方案。柯克布赖德在“朋友精神病院”工作了几年，学习并实践了道德治疗。1840年，他成为了自己精神病院——宾夕法尼亚精神病院的院长。正是在这里，他开始思考治疗精神失常的另一种方式。
another way to treat insanity. More specifically, he started thinking a lot about the environment where patients were treated. Because there was a word for the mentally ill in the basement, patients were kept in Because there was a ward for the mentally ill in the basement, patients were kept in very small cells, and I think they were given food, maybe blankets, but not much more than that. And it was in a spirit of reforming that basement ward that Kirkbride tried to think about a new way to treat people.
更具体地说，他开始深入思考病人接受治疗的环境。因为当时地下室里有一个精神病区，病人们被关在非常小的牢房里，我想他们能得到食物，也许还有毯子，但仅此而已。正是出于改革那个地下室病区的精神，柯克布赖德试图思考一种治疗人的新方法。
As part of a push to get patients out of that prison-like basement, the hospital had already commissioned a brighter, more spacious building in the countryside. But Kirkbride came to believe that even this wasn't enough. Specifically, he wished an asylum superintendent like him, who actually treated insanity, had been consulted when the building had been designed. So a few years later, when he was finally given the opportunity to construct his own facility for the hospital, Kirkbride began to experiment.
作为将病人从那种监狱般的地下室中解救出来的一部分，医院已经委托在乡村建造一座更明亮、更宽敞的建筑。但柯克布赖德开始认为这还不够。具体来说，他希望在设计建筑时，能咨询像他这样真正治疗精神失常的精神病院院长。因此，几年后，当他终于有机会为医院建造自己的设施时，柯克布赖德开始进行实验。
The architecture of the building, the landscaping of its grounds, the efficiency of its operation, even the demeanor of the staff. Nothing was left to chance. And when he was done, he sat down everything he learned in an extremely detailed book called on the construction, organization, and general arrangements of hospitals for the insane with some remarks on insanity and its treatment. It's a how-to book. A book on how to construct the perfect asylum. There's a illustration of the model asylum. There are pages and pages
建筑的结构、场地的景观、运营的效率，甚至员工的举止。没有任何事情是留给偶然的。当他完成后，他将自己学到的一切写进了一本极其详尽的书里，书名是《关于精神病院的建设、组织和一般安排，附带关于精神失常及其治疗的评论》。这是一本操作指南。一本关于如何建造完美精神病院的书。书中有模范精神病院的插图。有许多页关于如何设计供暖系统，如何处理自来水。书中描述了如何设计窗户，使其看起来像普通窗户，但也能防止病人自杀。那个时代的大多数病人都是由家人送来的，没有自由，但柯克布赖德不想让人们觉得他们是在监狱里。所以精神病院周围的围栏也被伪装起来了。他建议挖一条沟，
about how to design the heating system, what to do about running water. There are descriptions of how to design the windows so that they look like ordinary windows, but also so they would prevent patient suicides. Most patients of this era were committed by their families and wouldn't be free to go, but Kirkbred didn't want people to feel like they were in a jail. So the fence around the asylum was also disguised. So he recommends building a trench,
让它慢慢向下倾斜，然后把墙建在沟里，再在另一边建起来。这样病人就不可能逃跑，或者他们用的词是“私奔”。病人不可能“私奔”，但从医院内部看不到一堵巨大的、阴森的墙。但柯克布赖德为这座未来精神病院/医院计划中最引人注目的方面，不是窗户、围栏或管道。而是建筑的形状。一种浅V形，就像一群飞行的鸟。V形由两组发散的病房或展馆组成。
kind of slowly slopes down, then you put the wall in the trench, and then you build it back up on the other side. That way it still wouldn't be possible for a patient to escape, or the word they used was ilope. It's not possible for a patient to ilope, but you can't see a big looming giant wall from inside the hospital. But the most striking aspect of Kirkbride's plan for this asylum-slash hospital of the future wasn't the windows or the fences or the plumbing. It was the building's shape. A shallow V shape like a row of birds in flight. The V consisted of two diverging series of wards or pavilions.
新来的病人会到达V形中心的一栋行政大楼。从那里开始，病人首先按性别隔离，男性去一侧，女性去另一侧。然后他们会根据四种不同的需求水平按病情进行隔离。科里·法比安·巴雷特说，需要最多护理的病人会被安置在离中心最远的展馆里，这意味着随着病情好转，你实际上会向出口移动。所以这种乐观的哲学是，你刚来时状况很糟糕，
New arrivals would arrive at the administrative building in the center of the V. From there, patients would be first segregated by gender, men going to one side, women to the other. They would then be segregated by condition, according to four distinct levels of need. Cory Fabian Barrett says that patients requiring the most care would be kept in the pavilions furthest from the center, which meant that as you improved, you'd literally move towards the exit. So the kind of optimistic philosophy there is you'd show up in the, you'd in terrible shape,
你需要很多帮助，你被送到第五栋楼。建筑和柯克布赖德计划的魔力治愈能力，加上保持活跃，会让你好转一点，然后你会去四号楼，接着是三号、二号、一号，然后你就会走出前门。由于每个展馆都比前一个稍微向后退缩，护理人员可以轻松打开四面的窗户，有助于通风。各部分之间狭窄的接触点也防止了火灾，
you need so much help, you're sent to the fifth building. The magical curative powers of the architecture and the Kirk-Bride plan and keeping active would make you a little bit better and you'd go to four and then three, two, one, and then you'd walk out the front doors. Since each of the pavilions would be set back slightly from the last, attendance could easily open windows on all four sides, aiding in ventilation. The narrowed points of contact between sections also protected against
使得更容易将设施的任何一部分与其他部分隔离开来。大自然本身被认为是具有治愈作用的，因此柯克布赖德要求精神病院被公园绿地环绕。这意味着当你走在建筑层叠的走廊和高高的天花板下时，你转向几乎任何方向，都能看到高耸的绿地和天空景观。其理念是让精神病院感觉像一个维多利亚时代的家，每个病房都应该像一个理想的维多利亚家庭单位。所以他们在一起做所有事情。
fire, making it easier to seal off any one part of the facility from the others. Nature itself was thought to be curative, and so Kirkbride called for the asylum to be surrounded by parkland. That meant as you walked down the building's tiered corridors with their tall ceilings, in almost every direction you turned, you would see towering landscapes of greenery and sky. The idea was for the asylum to feel like a Victorian home, and each word was supposed to be structured like an ideal Victorian family unit. So they all do everything together.
医生在桌子尽头和他们一起用餐，以塑造理想的维多利亚式父亲形象。女管家在桌子的另一端，是母亲，他们都表现得像一家人。如果这个场景让你觉得有点家长作风，那在当时并不罕见。整个道德改革运动正围绕着社会有义务为不幸者提供照顾的理念而建立。就像父亲应该供养他的孩子一样。最著名的改革者之一是一位来自马萨诸塞州的老师，
The doctor has meals with them at the head of the table to model an ideal Victorian fatherhood. The matrons is at the other end of the table, is the mother, and they're all acting like this family. And if that scene strikes you as a bit paternalistic, that wasn't unusual for the time. A whole moral reform movement was building around the idea that society had a duty to provide care for the less fortunate. Much like a father should provide for his children. One of the most famous reformers was a teacher
名叫多萝西娅·迪克斯。迪克斯在全国巡回演讲，统计并撰写关于她所称的“精神失常穷人”状况的报告。她写了强有力的演讲稿，然后让男人们代她发表。作为女性，她被禁止亲自向州议会发言。尽管如此，她还是让20个州为公共精神病院提供了资金。
from Massachusetts, named Dorthia Dix. Dix toured the country, counting and writing reports on the condition of what she called the insane poor. She wrote powerful speeches she'd then have men deliver on her behalf. As a woman, she was barred from speaking herself to state legislatures. Nonetheless, one by one, she got 20 states to fund public assilums.
所以它们是用纳税人的钱支付的。那是一个美国各州几乎不支付任何费用的时代。他们几乎连道路的费用都不支付。柯克布赖德和迪克斯经常通信，是资助精神病院斗争中的盟友。他甚至在书中专门写了一节，针对迪克斯会游说的那些官员。他提醒他们，任何人，包括他们自己，都可能精神失常。这与他们的种族、信仰或阶级无关。柯克布赖德称精神失常为“伟大的平衡器”。
And so they were paid for with taxpayers' dollars. And this was a time when American states didn't pay for much of anything. They barely paid for roads. Kirkbride and Dix corresponded frequently, allies in the battle to fund assilums. He even included a section in his book addressed to the same officials' dicks would have been lobbying. He reminded them that anyone including them could go insane. It didn't matter their race or creed or class. Kirkbride called insanity the great leveler.
所以，当那本标题优雅的《关于精神病院的建设、组织和一般安排，附带关于精神失常及其治疗的评论》上架时，它非常受欢迎。它内容非常密集。如果你今天读它，你无法相信这在当时会很受欢迎，但那是1854年，人们喜欢它。精神病院开始在全国各地涌现。1840年，美国只有18家。
So when the elegantly titled on the construction, organization, and general arrangement of hospitals for the insane with some remarks on insanity and its treatment hit the stands. It was wildly popular. It's super dense. If you read it today, you can't believe that this was popular, but it was 1854 and people loved it. Asylums began popping up all across the country. In 1840, the United States had just 18.
到1880年，有139家。其中大多数是用州政府资金建造的，并按照柯克布赖德计划设计。该计划为建筑师提供了建造美丽、功能最佳的精神病院所需的一切。凭借其独特的V形，它们很快被称为“柯克布赖德”。这就是纽约州布法罗市最终拥有科里·法比安·巴雷特之前带我参观的那座巨大柯克布赖德建筑的原因。这座建筑是激烈竞争的结果。
By 1880, there were 139. Most of them were built with state funds, and were designed in accordance with the Kirkbride plan. The plan gave an architect everything they'd need to build a beautiful, optimally functional asylums. With their distinctive V-shape, they were soon known simply as Kirkbrides. Which is how the city of Buffalo, New York ended up with that giant Kirkbride that Cory Fabian Barrett was showing me around earlier. This building was a result of intense competition.
任何有自尊心的美国城镇都迫切希望拥有自己的柯克布赖德。它会被视为就业和声望的来源。因此，当纽约州议会在1865年同意资助一家新的精神病院以服务该州西部时，整个纽约西部地区对于这家医院将建在哪里展开了巨大的竞争。巴达维亚、洛克波特、布法罗和其他一些小城镇都在争夺投标。布法罗最终获胜，通过提供永久性的免费供水给医院。州政府不惜成本。他们聘请了中央公园的共同设计师弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德，
Any self-respecting American town desperately wanted its own Kirkbride. It would be seen as a source of jobs and prestige. So when the New York legislature agreed to fund a new asylum in 1865 to serve the western half of the state. There's a huge competition throughout western New York region about where this hospital is going to go. Batavia, Lockport, Buffalo, a few other smaller towns are all jostling for the bid. Buffalo ends up winning, Haza, by offering a perpetual supply of free water to the hospital. The state spared no expense. They hired Frederick Law Olmsted,
用数百英亩的景观美化设施。19世纪伟大的建筑师之一H.H.理查森设计了建筑的外观，并在顶部加上了两座巨大的铜顶塔楼，几乎就像大教堂的塔楼。至于它们是用来做什么的，这是我关于那些塔楼最常被问到的问题之一，比如，上面有什么？比如，他们在那些塔楼里做什么？
the co-designer of Central Park, to surround the facility with hundreds of landscaped acres. And one of the great architects of the 19th century H. H. Richardson designed the building's exterior, topping it off with two enormous copper-cited towers, almost like the towers of a cathedral. As for what they were for, that's one of the top questions I get about those towers, like, what was up there? Like, what were they doing in those towers?
什么都没有。它们从第一天起就是纯粹的装饰。虽然很难相信一个州立项目会花那么多钱和精力在两座巨大的装饰性塔楼上，但这正是他们在19世纪70年代所做的。但布法罗精神病院的外观宏伟与内部发生的事情相比根本不算什么。医院几乎像城镇一样运作。它们是微观城市。它们拥有小城镇所需的一切。柯克布赖德认为让病人忙碌是他们康复的关键，所以许多精神病院拥有完整的农场，部分由病人负责。
And nothing. They were purely decorative from day one. And it is hard, as hard it is as to believe that a state project would spend all that money and effort on two massive decorative towers that is exactly what they did in the 1870s. But the exterior grandeur of the Buffalo asylum was nothing compared to what was going on inside. Hospitals operated almost as towns. They were cities in microcosm. They had a full complement of everything a small town would need. Kirkbride believed that patients being occupied was key to their recovery, so many asylums contained full working farms, staffed in part by patients.
奶牛、猪、马、鸡。是的，它在某种程度上是自给自足的吗？是的，确实如此。柯克布赖德精神病院有保龄球馆、舞厅和棒球场。其中一个甚至有一种类似电动过山车的东西。波基普西的精神病院有一个九洞高尔夫球场。人们甚至可以购买印有当地柯克布赖德精神病院精美图画的明信片。就像，达琳小姐，这是一张精神病院的蜡笔画。
Cows, pigs, horses, chickens. Yeah, like was it self-sustaining to a certain degree? It was, yeah. Kirkbrides had bowling alleys, dance halls, and baseball diamonds. One even had a kind of pre-electric roller coaster. The asylum in Pekipsi had a nine-hole golf course. People could even purchase postcards featuring a lovely drawing of the area's Kirkbride. Like, Miss Udarlene, here's a pastel of a lunatic asylum.
就像字面意思一样，精神病院已经成为公民和社会成就的象征，所有这些都建立在对精神失常可能治愈的信念之上。但从一开始，社会对这些建筑的雄心与建筑的实际运作方式之间就存在差距。首先，19世纪末建造的许多州立精神病院的规模最终适得其反。柯克布赖德曾坚持认为，院长应该能够探望每一位病人，因此精神病院最多只能容纳250名病人。
Like literally yes, asylums had become symbols of civic and social achievement, all resting on the belief in insanity's possible cure. But from their inception, there was a gap between society's ambitions for these buildings and how the buildings actually functioned. For one thing, the very size of many of the state asylum's built in the late 19th century ended up working against them. Kirkbride had been adamant a superintendant should be able to visit each and every patient so that an asylum should be 250 patients maximum.
但精神病院院长面临财务压力。他们想把精神病院的最大规模增加到600人，以接收更多的病人。因此，在院长年度会议上，他们进行了投票。柯克布赖德投票反对该措施，但它还是通过了。所以当H.H.理查森在19世纪70年代初设计布法罗精神病院时，他将其设计为最大容纳600人。所以护理人员永远不够，护士也不够，这破坏了道德治疗的所有方面。
But asylum superintendents were under financial pressure. They wanted to increase the maximum asylum size to 600 to take on more pain patients. So with the superintendents' annual meeting, they held a vote. Kirkbride voted against the measure, but it passed anyway. So when H. H. Richardson designed the Buffalo Hospital for the insane in the early 1870s, he designed it for the maximum 600. So there were never enough attendance, there weren't enough nurses, which ruins all of the aspects of the moral treatment.
但更大的问题是，许多住在柯克布赖德精神病院的病人并没有离开。从一开始，理念就是任何一家柯克布赖德医院的病人很快就会被治愈，不断为新病人腾出空间。所以你应该来到这里，待在这里，吸收柯克布赖德式的益处，不超过一年，然后你就被治愈了，然后回家。这在实践中根本不是这样运作的。柯克布赖德本人声称他在费城的精神病院治愈率达到80%。其他院长声称治愈率高达90%甚至100%。但医生们一直在收集和报告他们自己的数据。所以一个在精神病院去世的人可能被算作治愈，
But the larger problem was that many patients staying at Kirkbrides didn't leave. From the beginning, the idea had been that patients in any one Kirkbr hospital would soon be cured continually making room for new patients. So you're supposed to come here, be here, take in the Kirkbrighty goodness for no more than a year, and then you're cured and you go home. This is not how it works in practice at all. Kirkbright himself claimed that his asylum in Philadelphia had an 80% curate. Other superintendents claimed rates as high as 90 or even 100%. But the doctors had been collecting and reporting their own data. So a person who died in an asylum might be counted as cured,
而一个需要第二次就诊的病人可能被算作两个人被治愈。结果是，一旦柯克布赖德精神病院开业，它很快就会住满并保持这种状态。人们在这里待的时间长得多，他们意识到在医院开业两三年内，你知道吗，这作为急性护理设施行不通。我们是一个长期护理场所，我们没有足够的空间来做那个。
while a patient who required a second visit might be counted as two people cured. The result was that once a Kirk-Bride asylum opened, it quickly filled up and stayed that way. People are staying here much, much longer, and they realize that within two or three years of the hospital opening, you know what, this doesn't work as an acute care facility. We're a long-term care place, and we don't have enough space to be that.
所以，它们变成了非常贫穷和非常生病的人最终度过余生的地方，20年、30年、40年。到了20世纪中叶，这些建筑已经人满为患，病人数量远超柯克布赖德的想象。例如，布法罗的精神病院，回想一下，它是为600人设计的。在这家医院的鼎盛时期，也就是20世纪50年代，这里住着3600名病人。
So, they became places where people who were very poor and very sick ended up living their entire lives, 20, 30, 40 years. By the mid-20th century, the buildings had become overcrowded with far more patients than Kirkbride would have ever dreamed. Buffalo's asylum, for example, which recall was designed for 600. At the height of this hospital, which was in the 1950s, there were 3600 patients living here.
20世纪初建造的州立精神病院规模更大，看起来像监狱一样的机构建筑。这正是柯克布赖德想要避免的。位于长岛扎伊佩克斯最大的朝圣者州立医院容纳了超过14000名病人。到1955年，超过50万美国人被关在州立精神病院。所以它们变成了人类的仓库，并因导致精神失常而不是治愈它而受到批评。与此同时，精神病学家将注意力转向治愈现在被称为“精神疾病”的疾病。他们专注于身体干预，如
The state mental hospitals constructed during the early 20th century grew even larger, and there resembled institutional buildings like prisons. This was the very thing Kirkbrbright had wanted to avoid. The largest Pilgrim State Hospital on Long Island at Zaypex housed over 14,000 patients. By 1955 more than half a million Americans were confined in state mental hospitals. So they became warehouses for humans and they were criticized for causing insanity rather than curing it. Meanwhile, psychiatrists had turned their focus to curing what were now termed mental illnesses. They focused on physical interventions like
脑叶切除术、胰岛素昏迷、电休克治疗，最终是作为精神药物销售的化学物质。20世纪60年代，新法律禁止精神病患者工作。没有了病人劳动力的贡献，许多医院的基础设施陷入停滞。20世纪70年代，美国州立精神病院在所谓的“去机构化”过程中被大量削减资金、清空并关闭。布法罗的柯克布赖德精神病院最终于1974年关闭。其剩余的少数病人被转移到隔壁较小的设施。
lobotomies, insulin comas, electroshock treatments, and eventually chemicals marketed as psychiatric drugs. In the 1960s, new laws prohibited psychiatric patients from working. Without the contribution of patient labor, many hospitals' infrastructures were brought to a halt. In the 1970s, American state mental hospitals were largely defunded, emptied and shuttered during what was called de-institutionalization. The Kirkbride in Buffalo was finally shut down in 1974. Its fewer remaining patients transferred to a smaller facility next door.
到那时，这些建筑及其同类建筑的原始目的几乎已被遗忘。精神病院沦为流行文化的比喻。一个完全建立在它们最后一个可怕篇章上的比喻。欢迎来到阿卡姆，蝙蝠侠。以蝙蝠侠的阿卡姆疯人院为例，它坐落在哥谭市外，独自矗立在山上，拥有宏伟的哥特式建筑。别费心尖叫求救了。
By that time, almost everything about the original purpose of these buildings and others like them had been forgotten. Asylums were reduced to the role of a pop culture trope. One built entirely out of their last gruesome chapter. Welcome to Arkham, Batman. Take Batman's Arkham Asylum, sitting just outside Gotham, alone on a hill with its grand Gothic architecture. Don't bother screaming for help.
穿白大褂的人听不到你的声音。或者《飞越疯人院》中恐怖的机构噩梦。“我有我的香烟，请，拉奇德小姐。”顺便说一句，这部电影是在俄勒冈州的一家柯克布赖德精神病院拍摄的，许多真正的病人担任了临时演员。“我听到了你的问题，杰斯威克先生，一旦你冷静下来，我会回答你的问题。”然后还有FX瑞恩·墨菲剧集《美国恐怖故事：精神病院》第二季中的几乎任何内容。
The white coat's can't hear you. Or the terrifying institutional nightmare of one flu over the Kukuz nest. I have my cigarettes, please, Miss Ratchet. Which was incidentally filmed in a Kirkbride in Oregon, featuring many actual patients as extras. I heard your question, Mr. Jeswick, and I will answer your question as soon as you've calmed down. And then there's pretty much anything from season two
“请帮我离开这个地方！”“过来！”“电休克疗法是你建议的吗？”你知道，困扰我的是当他们试图让你承认这些地方很阴森时。克里斯·佩恩是一位摄影师，他可能比任何人都去过更多的柯克布赖德精神病院。他为一本名为《精神病院：州立精神病院封闭的世界内部》的书拍摄了30个州的70家废弃精神病院。这是一个被无休止地问到的问题，
of the FX Ryan Murphy Show American Horror Story, Asylum. Please help me out of the volume! Come here! Is electro shock therapy something you would suggest? You know, what bothers me is when they try to get you to admit that they're creepy places. Chris Payne is a photographer who's probably been inside more Kirkbrides than anybody else. He photographed 70 abandoned mental hospitals in 30 states for a book called Acylam inside the closed world of state mental hospitals. That's a question that gets asked endlessly,
就是，你知道，里面是什么样子的？阴森吗？你看到鬼了吗？我觉得它们不阴森。恰恰相反，我觉得能进入它们并拍摄它们很幸运。在成为摄影师之前，克里斯·佩恩实际上是一名建筑师。所以对他来说，这些地方利用建筑本身
is, you know, what was it like inside? Was it creepy? Did you see any ghosts? I didn't find them creepy. And at the very opposite, I felt lucky to be in them and to be able to photograph them. Before he was a photographer, Chris Payne was actually an architect. So to him, that these places used architecture itself
作为治疗手段，更令人印象深刻。我认为当你去建筑学院时，每个建筑师都梦想着他们的设计或建筑能影响某人，在那个层面上打动某人，改变他们的生活方式，改变他们的想法。这些建筑曾经拥有的改变人们想法的力量。这就是克里斯想要捕捉的一部分。因为很多东西已经被废弃了30、40年。一旦你处理了它，一旦你拆除了东西，
as treatment was all the more impressive. I think that when you go to architecture school, every architect dreams that their design or their building is going to sway someone, move someone on that level, change their lifestyle, change their mind. The power these buildings once had to change people's minds. That was part of what Chris wanted to capture. Because lots of things have been abandoned for 30, 40 years. And once you've handled it, once you strip things out,
当一件事开始倒塌在另一件事上时，它可能是任何废弃的建筑，它可能是任何东西。所以很难找到那些仍然完整且非常具体地体现这种生活方式的时刻。所以我花了几个小时、几天时间在里面拍照。克里斯发现，尽管几十年来年久失修，这些建筑依然美丽。光线依然通过庄严的窗户倾泻而入。
and one thing starts to fall in on each other, it could be any abandoned building, it could be anything. So it was very hard to find those moments that were still intact and that were very specific to this way of life. And so I spent hours, days, inside them taking pictures. And what Chris found is that despite decades of disrepair, the buildings were still beautiful. The light still flooded in through the stately windows.
130年前种下的树木已经长得高大而优雅。但他还发现了使柯克布赖德精神病院自给自足的证据。那是制作酸菜的地方，一个美容院。三件由病人手工制作的连衣裙。看到他的照片帮助我稍微想象了一下，当这些机构真正运作时，生活可能是什么样子。它们让我看到了一群人，他们在这种历史叙事中的沉默对我来说总是非常响亮，那就是病人本身。克里斯有一张照片我一直念念不忘。那是一个牙刷柜。它来自波基普西的哈德逊河州立精神病院。就像几十把牙刷，橙色、红色、绿色、蓝色、粉色，每一把都仔细贴上了标签。出于某种原因，当他们清空病房时，他们留下了这个牙刷柜，每一把上面都有病人的名字。这张照片说，这就是曾经有多少人把这里称为家。这就是曾经有多少人把他们的牙刷挂在这里。它还说明了这个空间被废弃得有多匆忙。
The trees planted 130 years ago had grown tall and graceful. But he also found evidence of what had made Kirkbride self-sustaining. That's for making Sourcrout, a beauty parlor. Three dresses handmade by Patience. Seeing his photos helped me imagine a little, what life might have been like at these institutions when they were truly operational. They gave me a little glimmer of a group of people whose silence in this historical
就像无论这些人接下来去了哪里，他们都没能带走他们的牙刷。在现存的几十座柯克布赖德建筑中，许多正在缓慢腐烂。它们被视为公共滋扰或昂贵的头痛。少数几家设法保持开放，尽管通常是在非常缩减的能力下。建筑的一小部分用于某种行政职能，而其余部分则被废弃。
narrative is always very loud to me, the patients themselves. There's this one photograph of Chris' I keep thinking about. There was a cabinet of toothbrushes. It had since Hudson River State Hospital in Pekipsi. Like dozens of toothbrushes, orange, red, green, blue, pink, each carefully labeled. And for some reason, when they emptied out the ward, they left this cabinet of this cupboard of toothbrushes, each with the patient's name on them. The image says, that's how many people once called this place home. That's how many people once hung their toothbrush here. And it says that this is how hastily this space was abandoned.
一些柯克布赖德建筑已经被或正在被改造成公寓。澳大利亚悉尼的另一家成为了艺术学校的所在地。还有华盛顿特区的柯克布赖德精神病院，圣伊丽莎白医院。它即将成为国土安全部的总部。至于布法罗的柯克布赖德精神病院，它也没有完全废弃。它的一部分现在是一家豪华酒店。科里·法比安·巴雷特告诉我，这是一个特别受欢迎的结婚地点，有时是因为这对夫妇对精神病院的历史感兴趣。
Like wherever these folks went next, they didn't get to bring their toothbrush. Of the few dozen Kirkbride buildings that are still standing, many are in the process of slowly decaying. They're regarded as public nuisances or expensive headaches. A handful have managed to stay open, though often in a very diminished capacity. A small portion of the building used for some administrative function while the rest is abandoned.
虽然，她说，有时他们只是想要一个看起来像霍格沃茨的地方。漫步在酒店长而明亮的走廊里，我有时能瞥见精神病院仍然废弃的部分，就在隔壁的一个侧翼。在建筑的前面是这些看起来有点威胁的带笼子的门廊。我刚到时就注意到了它们，尽管实际上站在里面一点也不像我预期的那样。我们实际上可以去门廊上。
Some Kirkbright's have been or are being transformed into condos. Another one in Sydney, Australia, became home to an art school. And then there's the Kirkbride in Washington, D.C., St. Elizabeth's. It's about to become the headquarters for Homeland Security. As for the Kirkbride in Buffalo, it's not entirely abandoned either. Part of it is now a luxury hotel. Corey Fabian Barrett told me it's an especially popular spot to get married, sometimes because the couple is interested in the history of the asylum.
哦，这是一个门廊。是的。哇！找到我最喜欢的地方了。哦！我喜欢它。这是一个门廊。是的。哇！找到我最喜欢的地方了。哦！我喜欢它。是的。所以这是一个露台。
Although, other times she says, they just want a place that looks like Hogwarts. Strolling the hotels, long, bright hallways, I could sometimes catch a glimpse of the still abandoned part of the asylum just one wing over. On the building's front were these somewhat menacing looking caged in porches. I noticed them when I first arrived, although actually standing in one had been nothing at all like I'd expected. We can go out on the porch, actually.
对。它不是一个笼子。是的。所以这是我带人参观时最喜欢去的地方之一，因为他们，我是第一个承认的人，从外面看它们看起来很糟糕。它们确实看起来像个笼子。但一旦你真正站在里面并走出去，你就会得到一个完全不同的视角。你会觉得，哦，是的，
Oh, this is a porch. Yeah. Whoa! Find my favorite places. Oh! I love it. This is a porch. Yeah. Whoa! Find my favorite places. Oh! I love it. Yeah. So this is a terrace.
这会是一个不错的地方。是的，是的。当我们回来时，我们将与作家兼记者桑迪·艾伦谈谈柯克布赖德的理念在今天仍然存活的一种小方式。只是这一次，是在一个绝对没有被废弃的地方。请留下来。所以几年前，桑迪·艾伦偶然发现了一个与柯克布赖德今天的遗产相关的故事，他们在一个你可能意想不到的地方发现了它，那就是在美国精神医学学会的大型年度会议上。所以背景介绍一下，美国精神医学学会实际上是由托马斯·柯克布赖德在1844年共同创立的，
Right. It's not a cave. Yeah. So this is one of my favorite places to bring people on tours because they, I'm the first one to admit, they look terrible from the outside. They do look like a cage. But once you actually stand in them and get out in them, you get a totally different perspective. And you're like, oh, yeah
起初，大约有十几位精神病院院长聚在一起交流关于如何最好地利用他们的建筑来治愈病人的信息。今天，该组织完全不同了。大约有40000名精神病学家是会员，他们已经与制药行业纠缠在一起。所以桑迪参加了他们的年度会议，那一年他们在圣地亚哥举行，他们实际上是在举办动漫展的大型会议中心举行的。所以这有点像去动漫展，除了它全是关于精神药物的。
This would have been a nice spot. Yeah Yeah When we come back, we'll talk with writer and reporter Sandy Allen about one small way in which Kirkbrides' ideas have remained alive. Only this time, in a place that is most definitely not abandoned. Stay with us. So a few years ago, Sandy Allen came across a story related to Kirkbrides' legacy today, and they found it in a place you might not expect, which was at the big annual meeting of the American Psychiatric Association. So a little background, the APA was actually co-founded by Thomas Kirkbride in 1844,
就像在销售大厅，你知道，有巨大的横幅，从地板到天花板，像带有闪烁灯光和这种药、那种药、那种药、那种药的标志的大型旋转展示，还有所有这些漂亮的人试图和你交谈并给你甜点等等。而且，你知道，这全是那种
and at first it was about a dozen asylum superintendents who would come together to swap information about how to best use their buildings to cure patients. Today, the organization is totally different. There are about 40,000 psychiatrists who are members, and they've become pretty entangled with the pharmaceutical industry. So Sandy was at their annual conference, which that year they were having in San Diego, and they were actually having it at the big convention hall where they do Comic-Con. So it was kind of like going to Comic-Con, except it was all about psych meds.
专注于我们如何改变那个被认为以某种方式“犯错”的个体。所以这与我们在关于柯克布赖德的故事中听到的非常不同，那个故事是关于道德治疗以及改变一个人的环境真的可以提供帮助的理念。
It's like on the sales floor, you know, it's like these huge banners, Florida ceiling, like big rotating displays with flashing lights and the logos of this pill and this pill and this pill and this pill and all these nice, pretty people trying to talk to you and hand you sweet treats and so on. And, you know, it was all this sort of stuff
是的，完全正确。在那天美国精神医学学会博览会上我看到的所有东西中，有一件小东西确实让我想起了那种更古老的方法，那种不同的方法。它与我看到的其他一切都不同，它真的让我印象深刻，也许是字面意义上的，因为我吃了它。那是一块奶酪。
that's focused on how do we like change that one individual who's perceived as being somehow like, errant. So very different from what we heard about in the story about Kirkbride, which is about moral treatment and this idea that altering a person's environment can really help.
几个月后，我去见了那个帮助制作它的人。我是何塞·维列加斯，来自委内瑞拉加拉加斯。所以何塞住在马萨诸塞州的黄金农场并制作奶酪。如果美国精神医学学会的会议代表了现代精神治疗中的主流思想，那么黄金农场就是一个很好的例子，说明柯克布赖德式的理念无论如何仍然存活。那么告诉我们更多关于黄金农场以及它是如何让其中一些理念存活下来的。
Yeah, exactly. And of all the things I saw that day at the APA fair, there was one little something that did remind me of that older idea of that different approach. It was unlike everything else I saw, and it really stuck with me, perhaps literally, because I ate it. It was a piece of cheese.
嗯，首先，黄金农场是一个真正的农场。他们在马萨诸塞州西部一个超级美丽的地方——伯克希尔拥有700英亩土地，它是一个多世纪前，即1913年由一个叫威尔·戈尔德的人创办的。所以这是柯克布赖德去世30年后。威尔·戈尔德非常虔诚，非常热衷于在乡村拥有一个欢迎那些被社会排斥的人的地方，那是他的神圣使命。
And a couple of months later, I went to meet the man who helps make it. I'm Jose Villegas, originally from Caracas, Venezuela. So Jose lives and makes cheese at this place called gold farm in Massachusetts. And if the APA meeting represents kind of the mainstream thinking in modern psychiatric treatment, then gold farm is a great example of how Kirkbrightian ideas remain alive anyway. So tell us more about gold and how it has kept some of those ideas alive.
快进一个世纪，黄金农场在某些方面确实不同了。它规模更大，基础更稳固，它是世俗的，但今天它仍然完全专注于最初的理念，提供一个农场，让有严重精神挑战的人可以留下来工作并有望康复。所以奶酪商何塞经历过艰难的生活。他小时候经历过虐待。他大约35年前搬到东海岸，作为一个成年人，他进进出出精神病院，最终变得非常孤立。最终一位医生告诉他这个农场，起初
Well, first, gold farm is a real farm. They've got 700 acres in this super beautiful part of western Massachusetts called the Berkshires, and it was started over a century ago in 1913 by a guy named Will Gold. So this is 30 years after Kirkbright's death. And Will Gold was really Christian and really into the idea that having a place in the countryside that was welcoming toward people who were being outcast from society, that was his divine mission.
他真的很怀疑。他完全是一个城市人，我从没想过我能在这样的地方生存。但当他到达黄金农场时，他立刻就能看出它与他住过的其他机构不同。所以首先，在普通的心理健康护理机构，医生和员工通常会穿制服，而在黄金农场，每个人都只是穿着卡其裤和对讲机。她是直接协议的负责人。我们有政策
And fast forward a century, and Gold Farm is really different in some senses. It's much larger, it's better established, it's secular, but it's still today totally focused on that original idea, providing a farm where people with severe psychiatric challenges can stay and work and hopefully recover. So the cheese monger Jose had had a tough life. He had experienced abuse as a kid. He moved to the East Coast about 35 years ago and as an adult he'd been in and out of psych hospitals and he'd ended up very isolated. And eventually a doctor tells him about this farm and initially
在紧急情况下迅速响应以缓和局势，通过心理健康重新获得许可，但看起来我们并没有把所有这些东西都穿在袖子上。或者你在普通精神病院永远看不到的另一件事。我们所有的门从来没有锁过。坦率地说，我没有办公室的钥匙。我们的车从来没有锁过，这适用于我们所有人。
he was really skeptical. It was totally a city person and I never thought that I could survive in a place like this. But when he got to gold farm right away he could tell it was different than other institutions where he'd stayed. So for one at a regular mental health care facility, usually doctors and staff would be wearing uniforms and at gold farm at everybody was just wearing khakis and walkie talkies puts it. She's the direct protocols. We have policies
他当时非常怀疑。他完全是个城里人，从没想过自己能在这种地方生存下来。但当他来到黄金农场时，他立刻感觉到这里和其他他待过的机构不同。首先，在普通的心理健康护理机构，医生和员工通常会穿制服，而在黄金农场，每个人都只是穿着卡其裤，带着对讲机。她说，这是直接的规程。我们有政策。
respond quickly in an emergency to deescalate, relicens by, you mental health, but to look we don't wear all of those things on our sleeve. Or something else you'd never see at a regular psych hospital. None of our doors are ever locked. I frankly don't have a key to my office. Our cars are never locked, and that goes through all of us.
在紧急情况下迅速响应以缓和局势，这属于心理健康范畴，但你看，我们并没有把这些条条框框挂在身上。还有一些你在普通精神病院绝对看不到的东西。我们所有的门从来都不上锁。坦白说，我办公室的钥匙都没有。我们的车也从不上锁，我们所有人都是这样。
Lissanne explained Gold Farm is a community, and communities are all about trust. So it's definitely not the big iron fence philosophy of mental health care. Right, definitely not. So what happens after Jose arrives? He notices it all looks very different, it feels very different, and then what happens next with him?
Lissanne解释说，Gold Farm是一个社区，而社区的核心就是信任。所以这绝对不是那种用铁栅栏围起来的心理健康护理理念。没错，绝对不是。那么Jose到达之后发生了什么？他注意到这里看起来很不一样，感觉也很不一样，接下来他身上发生了什么？
Well, Jose is a really tall guy, and back then he was also really heavy, and he'd become really afraid of even trying simple things, because he was afraid he might break something or drop something and people might think he was a clots. I never had confidence to know he would bring vicious from the kitchen into the dining room. But when a new guest like Jose arrives at the farm, they're immediately absorbed into the farm's daily working life, so maybe they're on the nursery crew. Maybe they're in the forest and grounds crew clearing paths. It might be winter and it's sap season, and so you'll be out in the woods, tapping trees and hanging buckets and collecting sap,
嗯，Jose是个个子很高的人，当时他的体重也很重，他变得非常害怕尝试简单的事情，因为他担心自己可能会弄坏什么东西，或者掉落什么东西，然后人们会觉得他是个笨手笨脚的人。我从来没有信心他能把盘子从厨房端到餐厅。但是，当像Jose这样的新客人来到农场时，他们会立即融入农场的日常工作生活中，所以他们可能会加入托儿所小组。也许他们会在森林和场地小组清理小路。如果是冬天，正是采集树液的季节，所以你会在树林里，给树钻孔、挂桶并收集树液，
employing it down into maple syrup. So everyone at Gold Farm has a job and the entire staff lives there and works there too. Lissanne and her family live on the farm as do their roughly 40 staff members. And how big is the farm? Like how many patients live there? Well, for one thing, they're not called patients
然后将其加工成枫糖浆。所以Gold Farm的每个人都有工作，所有的员工也住在那里并工作在那里。Lissanne和她的家人住在农场，大约40名员工也住在那里。农场有多大？有多少病人住在那里？嗯，首先，他们不被称为病人，
while they're there. They're called guests, which is a very deliberate choice they've made with the language. So about 40 guests live at the farm at any given time. The people who come here include people who are managing mental health challenges like schizophrenia, schizophrenia, effective disorder bipolar major depression. These are typically folks who've experienced plenty of the traditional American mental health care system and still like Jose have found themselves struggling. But for him, everything changed when he got to gold farm and started getting curious about cheese.
在他们待在那里的时候。他们被称为客人，这是他们在用词上做出的一个非常慎重的选择。所以任何时候大约有40位客人住在农场。来到这里的人包括那些正在应对精神健康挑战的人，比如精神分裂症、分裂情感性障碍、双相情感障碍、重度抑郁症。这些人通常是经历过很多传统美国心理健康护理系统，但像Jose一样仍然感到挣扎的人。但对他来说，当他来到Gold Farm并开始对奶酪产生好奇时，一切都改变了。
You know, at some point I said, can I kind of start making cheese? He tried it, he liked it, and he got really into it. And cheese takes some commitment. Getting up in the four o'clock in the morning because at that time we used to pasteurize the milk and make the cheese. For Jose, it was when he was learning to make cheese and gaining the confidence to walk a plate
你知道，在某个时候我说，我可以开始尝试制作奶酪吗？他试了试，他很喜欢，并且非常投入。制作奶酪需要一些承诺。早上四点起床，因为那时我们过去常常要给牛奶消毒并制作奶酪。对于Jose来说，当他学习制作奶酪并获得信心去端盘子时，
across the dining room or learning to do dishes or learning to cook and taking taking walks, and making friends, and just being in this beautiful, natural place that all these things, his self-image, started to fundamentally change. And I started to develop a lot more confidence of myself, I didn't see myself as a clots anymore, or as a social reject.
穿过餐厅，或者学习洗碗，或者学习做饭，散步，结交朋友，仅仅是待在这个美丽的自然环境中，所有这些事情，他的自我形象开始发生根本性的改变。我开始对自己有了更多的信心，我不再把自己看作是一个笨手笨脚的人，或者是一个社会弃儿。
Jose eventually even worked at Gould Farms Roadside Diner, which is another thing that's really unique about this place. So at the diner, guests are servers and cooks. They are dealing with the public, topping off coffees, selling homemade bagels in these big gigantic pancakes. And you can, I think, really hear an echo back to Kirkbride in that idea of giving people meaningful work, you know, helping someone feel like they're competent and useful. It's so unlike the mental health care status quo where, you know, people are being shut up in
Jose最终甚至在Gould Farms的路边餐馆工作，这也是这个地方非常独特的一点。在餐馆里，客人担任服务员和厨师。他们与公众打交道，续咖啡，卖自制的百吉饼和这些巨大的煎饼。我想，你真的可以从那种给人们提供有意义的工作的想法中听到对Kirkbride的回响，你知道，帮助某人感到他们是有能力和有用的。这与心理健康护理的现状截然不同，你知道，人们被关在
some institutional building, told to wear pajamas all day in play cards. You know, here instead, you've got people who are presently receiving residential psychiatric treatment being given this tremendous challenge of running a restaurant and they are totally kicking butt at it. And so what's up with Jose now? Is he still a guest at Gold Farm? He's actually today he's a staff member at the farm and he's also what's called a certified peer specialist. So he's someone who's done this training and he has this firsthand experience
某个机构建筑里，被告知整天穿着睡衣玩纸牌。你知道，在这里，你反而有正在接受住院精神病治疗的人，被赋予了经营餐馆的巨大挑战，而且他们做得非常出色。那么Jose现在怎么样了？他还是Gold Farm的客人吗？他实际上今天已经是农场的员工了，他也是所谓的认证同伴专家。所以他是一个完成了这种培训，并且有这种第一手经验的人，
with psychiatric diagnosis being in treatment, that kind of stuff. And he's lending that expertise to other people who are presently figuring out their own recoveries. So Jose talked to me about how he used to feel like such an outsider. But now he's part of that community. And it's not just the gold farm community,
有精神病诊断，接受过治疗，诸如此类的事情。他正在将这种专业知识借给其他目前正在摸索自己康复之路的人。所以Jose跟我谈到了他过去是如何感到自己像个局外人的。但现在他是那个社区的一部分。而且不仅仅是Gold Farm社区，
but the wider community. There's this relationship between the farm and the town, which also feels very Kirkbright you know, locals have histories with the farm. They've had family and friends who've stayed there, worked there. I mean, some people even just go by the cafe for their morning coffee. There's a way in which the town's history is really intertwined with the farm's history and the farm's histories intertwined with the farm sister and the farm sister is intertwined with the town. And I think it matters that people who are in psychiatric treatment and those who aren't
而是更广泛的社区。农场和城镇之间存在这种关系，这也感觉非常Kirkbride，你知道，当地人与农场有历史渊源。他们有家人和朋友在那里住过、工作过。我的意思是，有些人甚至只是顺便去咖啡馆喝杯早咖啡。城镇的历史与农场的历史真正交织在一起，农场的历史与农场的历史交织在一起，农场的历史与城镇交织在一起。我认为，接受精神病治疗的人和那些没有接受治疗的人能够
are integrated, you know, that we have opportunities to be reminded of one another's humanity. I think it matters whether people who need mental health care have access to tools like supportive environments, opportunities to grow, to work, to socialize, to be outside. So in a way what we do here is as old as time and it's also the case that we know through contemporary research and studies that what we do here is important and makes a difference. So in the scheme of things, how rare is a place like Guld Farm? In America, really, really rare. You know, there's Guld Farm and a few others like it, some of which were directly based on Guld.
融合在一起是很重要的，你知道，我们有机会被提醒彼此的人性。我认为，需要心理健康护理的人是否能够获得支持性环境、成长机会、工作机会、社交机会、户外活动机会等工具，这很重要。所以从某种意义上说，我们在这里所做的事情和时间一样古老，而且我们也通过当代的研究和调查知道，我们在这里所做的事情很重要，并且有所作为。那么从大局来看，像Guld Farm这样的地方有多罕见？在美国，真的，非常罕见。你知道，有Guld Farm和其他少数几个类似的地方，其中一些是直接基于Guld建立的。
We, the taxpayers, do spend a lot of money on mental health care, but it is not going towards studying or funding approaches like this. We don't receive any government funding, and there's really no insurance reimbursements for people in a residential program. They're a nonprofit and therefore a reliant on constant fundraising. This is expensive care to provide. That said, the folks I met at Gould
我们纳税人确实在心理健康护理上花费了很多钱，但它并没有用于研究或资助这样的方法。我们没有收到任何政府资助，而且住院项目的参与者也没有保险报销。他们是一个非营利组织，因此依赖于持续的筹款。这是一种昂贵的护理服务。话虽如此，我在Gould遇到的人
seemed really committed to their path. It isn't necessarily easy, but they do feel strongly it's right. And I'm not gonna lie, when with a situation regarding mental health care in America right now can feel pretty hopeless. So when I get to eat something as special as a piece of gold farm cheddar, I'm glad to feel a little bit of hope. Well, thanks so much, Sandy. Thank you.
似乎真的致力于他们的道路。这并不一定容易，但他们确实坚信这是正确的。我不会撒谎，当美国目前的心理健康护理状况让人感到相当绝望时。所以当我能吃到像Gold Farm切达干酪这样特别的东西时，我很高兴能感受到一点希望。嗯，非常感谢你，Sandy。谢谢你。
For much more from Sandy about mental health care in America, read their book, A Kind of Miraculous Paradise, a true story about schizophrenia. It was published by Scribner, and is now out in paperback. We also recommend you check out Sandy's new podcast, Mad Chat. The show Unpacks What Our Pop Culture is Telling us about Madness and Mental Health.
想要了解更多关于Sandy在美国心理健康护理方面的内容，请阅读他们的书《一种奇迹般的天堂：关于精神分裂症的真实故事》。它由Scribner出版，现在已经出了平装本。我们也建议你看看Sandy的新播客《Mad Chat》。该节目揭示了我们的流行文化告诉我们关于疯狂和心理健康的什么信息。
Their latest episode is actually about Batman, the animated series. It's somehow fascinating and funny and important all at the same time. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sandy Allen and edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mix and Technical Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Raeal. Katie Mingle is the senior producer. The rest of the team is me, Delaney Hall, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and Roman Mars.
他们最新的剧集实际上是关于《蝙蝠侠》动画系列的。它以某种方式既迷人又有趣，同时又很重要。99% Invisible本周由Sandy Allen制作，Joe Rosenberg编辑。混音和技术制作由Sheree Fusef负责，音乐由Sean Raeal创作。Katie Mingle是高级制作人。团队的其他成员是我，Delaney Hall，Avery Truffleman，Emmett Fitzgerald，Vivian Lee，Sophia Klatsker和Roman Mars。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW on San Francisco, and were produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I cannot do that as well as Roman. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet Roman Mars at Roman Mars. You can tweet me at DAP Hall.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，是在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作的。我无法像Roman那样做得那么好。99% Invisible是来自PRX的Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到他们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注Roman Mars @RomanMars。你可以在Twitter上关注我 @DAPHall。
And you can tweet the show at 99PIORG. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. We have links and pictures of some of the Kirkbrides we talked about at 99pi.org. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Twitter上关注该节目 @99PIORG。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。我们在99pi.org上有我们谈到的关于Kirkbrides的一些链接和图片。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。